journeys are measured in many ways
time and distance are obvious markers
but some journeys the most difficult
ones are harder to gauge Jill Hicks's
journey began 10 years ago in one
terrifying moment her life changed
forever I'd expected to see a monster
and I didn't see a monster I saw a young
man and I thought what in the hell has
led you a 19 year old man to detonate a
bomb to kill yourself to do this to me
to take so many lives and that was clear
in that moment from looking at that
picture and that was the beginning of my
journey
you
breaking news forgetting from the PA
news wire that there's been reports of
an explosion outside Liverpool Street
Station July the 7th 2005 morning rush
hour
Jill was on the tube the Piccadilly line
between Kings Cross and Russell Square
on the same train a suicide bomber one
of four who would bring carnage to the
category the likes of which had never
been witnessed in Britain before
Jill's injuries were so severe she
wasn't expected to survive I need to
understand this not only do I need to
understand it I need to be part of a
solution to never let this happen again
it's the big question isn't it how do we
stop this ever happening again and how
do we each play a role and that's what I
think is the continuous journey that is
still I'm still on ten years later so
we've got to look that way looking for
the cars in the decade that has passed
jill has forged a new life the one she
calls her second life she's divorced
fallen in love moved back to Australia
and given birth to daughter Emily
she has also committed her life to the
quest for peace
Jill's journey is shared by a community
also ripped apart by the 7/7 attacks but
for a very different reason
days after the explosions it emerged
that three of the four suicide bombers
all came from the same West Yorkshire
community Mohammad Sidique Khan
Shehzad Tanweer and Habib Hussain were
all raised in beeston a small lead
suburb this revelation that these mass
murderers who had once played on these
narrow streets as children threatened to
tear the community apart
we were not too shocked because
obviously there's some of the community
members knew those individuals you know
the perfectly decent people and you know
from school teacher to just young
ordinary you know teenagers beastin was
gripped by fear it was blamed for
nurturing and protecting Britain's first
suicide bombers I think certain members
of the community definitely felt that
fingers are pointed at them I describe
it as a combination of the most surreal
and traumatic experience I think I've
ever encountered individually absently
the organizations in Canada show the
community say they encountered when the
news is out there that actually it's an
individual from your area that committed
this there's naturally that that sense
of you know perhaps saying could my
neighbor do the same thing the community
closed ranks fair gave way to suspicion
suspicion turned to anger and hostility
towards outsiders the following weeks
months and years would prove challenging
many doubted Beeston would make it ten
years on Jill's journey her quest for
peace is taking her back to Beeston the
home of the men who tried to kill her
what's very interesting of course is
that people youngsters who were 10 years
old in Beeston who are now be 20 and I
think it's that that I'd be most
interested in hearing about of what is
the youth there today because did what
was the impact of July 7 on them as a
ten-year-old do they remember what that
was what that felt like what impact did
that have on them if there was them and
a 10 year old Muslim and feeling that
suddenly their front-page news
how did that impact their parents the
hemara Center is at the heart of
community life in Beeston 7/7 ringleader
Mohammed Sidique Khan was involved in
its youth work and it's here Jill came
two years after the bombings there was a
great pain from that community a great
sorrow that their boys had done such a
horrific act and I wanted to be the
bridge of that pain slightly
apprehensive in meeting with Jill
because obviously clearly aware of her
background and what had occurred but it
became very clear within the first five
minutes of beginning to talk to her that
this was an individual who wasn't really
caring that maybe at bitterness that I
thought might be might be resident in
her as a result of what had happened -
it was on this triple unity walk was
planned from Leeds to London
it took Jill one month to complete but
an agonizing six months to recover
it doesn't matter how many years have
passed I have at the anticipation that
we will meet his old friends today are
you anxious tall no not at all
my first instinct was to reach out and
in that reaching out metaphorically
their hands reached back and that was
the beginning of the relationship hello
let me be a gentleman
haven't changed you exactly musical
remarkable alright great thank you
damn you will see yeah I knew absolutely
he keeping will you look well great
seeing you you such an extensive but
just a go oh hello whitey make Emily
okay
is he little girl yeah she's tuna okay
baby chief Jimmy yesterday Tim I'm so
sorry I know I'm a Naima me hi darling
how are you
computerize we going it let's go it's
going
in the aftermath or 7/7 Amara was
involved with a lot worked travel make
sure the community remain deceive and
enhance community relations and Jill who
very unfortunately was caught on the on
the day itself on the attack was well I
don't know you guys all know me for ten
years and it's very rare loss for words
but Tim loss were hidden getting a bit
overwhelmed because he was absolutely
instrumental and she came up from London
and she did some amazing and initiatives
with her she was a keynote speaker at
our conference she did the walk talk she
actually walked from from Leeds to
London you know so as I say
it's not often I use the word inspired
or you know looking for inspiration from
from people may be other than historical
figures but particularly that email
hugely inspired you know I think it
still influences our work today but
she's actually come all the way from
Australia to you with so much focusing
in the spotlight being pop on Muslim
youth in particular on such a regular
basis that they are very integral to to
the debate and discussion do you see
them having been affected by growing up
oh yes shadow of July Civ yeah that
definitely not not only just in the
shadow of July the sermon but I think
everything that's occurred as I say
because so much has happened hasn't it
in ten years as a particularly globally
and when we've had the dialogue on the
discussion with them there's definitely
an impact but equally I have to say
they're still a very positive optimistic
outlook from them
because Muslims can't have images inside
the mosque yes and pictures and as a
result they're connected with God
through calligraphy through through
scripture and floral harmony so we got
both no scriptures here and also right
the top is like leaves and flowers
branching out to each other
Jill believes this engagement with young
Muslims is crucial the lure of Islamic
state for young Britons has shown the
need for a robust counter narrative it's
one that young Imams like Korea seem
inspired by Jill's work are trying hard
to deliver we don't want to even one
more young person losing his or her life
due to terrorism you know young Muslims
they're affected by by the terror that
may be caused elsewhere but if we live
in a global village where effects are
felt on the school playground they're
felt in an office they're felt just
people you know catching a same bus and
that feels further alienation
the next few days will inevitably bring
back the most painful of memories the
one thing that will give Jill Hicks the
strength to carry on is the hope that
her message of peace is getting through
my anger is what keeps me focused my
anger is what keeps me wanting to make a
positive difference and believing that
actually with all the billions of people
in the world there's actually more good
than there is bad and we've got to keep
reminding people that actually humanity
will prevail
I know that based on the last decade of
work that I will only be continuing the
journey that I've that I've started to
continuously work and advocate for a
piece for us to know in our lifetime but
more importantly for me to leave that
legacy to Emily and for her to know a
life without violent extremism that's
really important to me
you